.
Thank you.
All right.
How would you like?
I need some karaoke music.
Thank you.
Okay, good morning everyone.
Welcome to the Committee of Conference on House Bill 211.
I'm Representative Michael Bozen.
I'm gonna chair this Committee of Conference.
House Bill 211 was a simple housekeeping bill.
The Senate added two of its bills, Senate Bill 60 and Senate Bill 61, as amendments to the bill.
The Senate has since resolved issues that it had with those two bills.
So I'm going to ask that the Senate recede from its position of requesting an amendment to House Bill 211 and concur with the original House position.
We concur.
Okay.
And we thank you for the privilege of concurring with you.
Thank you.
We appreciate you being here to concur with us.
Mr.
Chair, I have a question.
Yes.
I'm interested to know, do we need to have any kind of amendment to strip those two out, or we just tell OLS to go with the underlying bill?
Essentially, when they say they accede to the House position, that means go with the underlying bill.
Okay.
Just wanted to clarify that.
Thank you.
And the report that OLS will create is in the form of an amendment, I believe.
Is that correct?
We can grant.
Grant Bossey with the New Hampshire Senate.
There are technically two versions of the bill before you, the House version and the Senate version.
They have each passed one chamber and have equal standing.
You will direct OLS to have a report that says the Senate agrees to the House position, which is the House passed bill.
That is the extent of the report.
You do not need any amendments.
That's what I was thinking.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thanks for that clarification.
All right.
So we'll just have a report.
No amendment required.
President of the chair?
Yes.
Go ahead.
Is there just a formal concurrence or a vote required for all of us here, for the record?
Good question.
We're supposed to vote separately, as I recall.
We voted yes.
And we can vote to accept their accession i accept you need a motion i move that we vote to accept the senate's a session okay all in favor hi hi okay all right we accept okay so we should celebrate with cake or something right yeah so I'll go over to OLS and I'll tell them what happened and they'll take it from there.
Thank you.
Okay.
Appreciate all your work.
Thank you.
We appreciate you guys being here.
Then there will be some paperwork we all have to sign.
So we'll all have to sign off.
Everybody has to sign off with OLS.
Or it's also possible, if you're not going to be here at the point when it becomes available then it's also possible to assign someone to sign it off for you usually and make sure you sign off by thursday afternoon at three o'clock no later than that so does does uh senator birdsall she has to sign she has to sign okay yep okay is she around today or no she's here but yeah It's just multitasking.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Is she around today or no?
She's here, but she's just multitasking.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Thank you.
All right.
Good enough.
Adjourned.
Thank you.
We'll now open the Committee of Conference on House Bill 607.
Welcome and thank you for coming.
I thought we might get started by first hearing from the senators.
It looks like you gutted House Bill 607 and made it a very different bill.
Would you care to enlighten us?
Sure.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
So 607 was the basic equivalent of Senate Bill 120, which passed both the House and the Senate and is on its way to the governor.
A vast majority of the provisions in 607 were already dealt with in 120.
I think it was 120.
But the one thing that we did when we raised the wagers and stakes, we didn't take into account, was what the rake was coming off the top.
In statute, it was fixed at 20%, which when we raised pots to 2,500, it's a $500 rake coming off the top, which makes it harder for the charitable gaming institutions to attract players with taking that much of the rake off the top.
And so what this bill does is seem to attract players.
We're taking that much of the rake off the top.
And so what this bill does is seem to limit that to, again, in favor of the player who will play to give them more money.
We amended this bill because of the provisions we're dealt with in other bills that we had the rake set at 20% or a maximum of $250, dollars which is still an increase of 50 percent over the current uh rake rake which is set at a if you have at 20 or a maximum of $250, which is still an increase of 50% over the current rake, which is set at a, if you had a $500 limit, it'd be $125.
So again, it was an unintended consequence of when we changed the bet limits, how much of the rake was taken.
That makes it so we're a little less competitive in this area.
I don't know if Sela Deisandre wants to add anything.
No, I think he's gone over it comprehensively.
You know what it was.
You know what it is.
It's the numbers.
It's the numbers that changed.
It seems to give a better situation for the player as well as for the house comments from the house side of things on the the house position the house budget how it compares to this amendment thoughts well i'd share you know where this is a totally different piece of legislation and I agree that 120 has a lot of the components.
The most disappointing component of this is the fact that the House had a pretty clear position on the moratorium on HHR, and where that, also in SB 51, was addressed, but subsequently vetoed, it's still my position and those of others that we need to take the time to review this new game, which was inadequately reviewed.
This doesn't allow for a proper review and we don't have to relive all the testimony that we've heard on both sides of the wall.
Fact remains is we're opening ourselves up without this moratorium on this specific game, without the ability to review its impact, most specifically on charities, but more the the the makeup and character of the state dependent on how many people apply for and receive licenses to hold this type of gaming activity i i know that we heard testimony from lottery that that no applications had come in for the last five years but if i read the governor governor's veto message on 51, apparently there's people in the queue that want these licenses.
Gee, I wonder why that is.
I think we need to be a little more measured in how we look at this, specifically the moratorium, specifically taking the opportunity with the Charitable Gaming Commission and other avenues to address what I foresee as a change possibly in the character.
I come from Salem.
It could be a change in the character of my town.
Okay, it's a border town.
Everybody and their brothers in there looking to get into gaming.
Okay, and it's because of this specific component, and we need to tap the brakes a little bit and look at what's going on with HHR, all components being considered, and most importantly, the effect on these charities.
Although we doubled the charities with this game.
Some of those charities have taken a loss, and I'm talking specifically about these legacy charities.
A couple in my town that have counted on and budgeted certain dollar figures that they've grown accustomed to getting through charitable gaming have taken a loss in those specific revenues because of promises that were made specific to this game coming on board, them having to split percentages with a doubling of the charities.
I don't think we've taken a good enough and and hard enough look at the impact of this game so my biggest contention here is this piece of legislation still needs to have a moratorium and it's the clear house position that that moratorium is a minimum of five years is that something the senate uh considered, well, would consider, has considered?
So, again, I think the veto message was pretty clear.
Putting a moratorium into this bill will just be a poison pill to the bill, which will be doing a disservice to the citizens of New Hampshire, as well as the charitable gaming operators and the charities themselves.
So I think that the Senate position would be a no to adding a moratorium into the Senate version.
And again, I think it does a disservice.
We still have some time left.
I will say that Senate Bill 51, which I was the prime sponsor on, did make it to the governor's desk and was vetoed.
I think I set a record.
I had this first veto last term and this first veto this term.
But that being said, again, I think that it's important to move this legislation forward for the operators and for the charities and for the citizens of New Hampshire and the players.
I do have one minor amendment.
Again, it had to do with Senate Bill 120.
We had a hard effective date on that, and we wanted to put a hard effective date on this so that they marry up as we increase the wagers in 120 that this rate piece will have the same implementation date as Senate bill 120 but I think that moratorium is a hard no I will say also that I was able to get the commission that was in one Senate bill 51 into the budget so there will be a study Commission on charitable gaming that is addressing HHR and looking at that.
I was going to say that we have a bill to study charitable gaming.
Senator Lange and I both brought in a legislation that we've morphed into.
I think points are well made, but I think looking at the big picture is very important.
As some of you know, I've been interested in gaming for a number of years and proposed a number of gaming bills that were defeated, passed by the Senate, but obviously always defeated by the House.
But I do believe that a strong, hard look at what's going on now is very important.
And all of the things that you mentioned have to be looked at and looked at carefully.
What we've seen is an expansion.
And as you say, some of the charities aren't doing as well as they have in the past.
That's a problem because the whole thing was geared around to charities receiving their 35%.
Bob O'Dell was very adamant about that.
We proposed a bill from Senate Ways and Means a number of years ago.
But the fact that we're going to take a hard look at it, I think the Commission is going to be put together by the governor and we're asking that a public member, it was my intent and I hope Senator Lang agrees, that a public member be chair of the commission so you get a good broad look at a person with some experience.
It really all needs to be looked at and looked at carefully.
I think there's a method in place to do the kinds of things that you would like to see done.
And I recognize what's going on in salem uh i i recognize what's going on in manchester uh and uh when you look at the television and just look at the ads that are now being posted on a regular basis uh about uh about gaming and about the participation in this in this field i think all of it needs to be looked at carefully.
I think the commission answers your problem.
It doesn't do it immediately in terms of a moratorium, but it does address the situation, which I think it's the big picture that has to be addressed very, very carefully.
Otherwise, this thing gets way out of hand.
That's a bad situation for New Hampshire, and I think it's a bad situation for the people.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
I'm glad to hear that you have the concern and the study committee makes sense because we don't want it to get out of hand I being also from Salem have a huge concern with this and it's almost like why are we looking at two extremes if the five-year moratorium is a non-starter the other extreme is having no moratorium especially where we recognize as you just said that we need to study this and understand what's going on.
So I would propose that let's at least put a two-year moratorium in so at least while the study commission is doing its work, we're not out in left field seeing stuff happening while we're studying it.
To be in concert and to have this sense, it's almost like we need some sort of moratorium, so let's make it two years.
Again, at least from my perspective, that's a non-starter.
We've already been there.
It's a poison pill.
I want to see this legislative change made.
I think if we add that provision, that is going to get us a guaranteed veto which gives us no no law to work with so i think the gaming operators and the players and the charities would prefer that we move something forward and what the senate's proposed in this bill knowing that we have a commission on the other side of this that'll will be signed into law as well.
It just was signed into law an hour ago.
So we know that this will be studied well, that the members of the commission is made up of a diverse group of people that have interest in both the public members, the charity members, the gaming operators, licensees, all are part of that participation to understand and get a good picture i think that adding a moratorium on top of this after would just be a non-starter we'd end up hurting both our charities and our gaming operators and our citizens and players Thank you.
When you designed Historic Horse Racing, you made sure that the towns would have absolutely no say in whether it came into their towns or not.
You're worried about your towns.
You have gambling towns.
I don't have a gambling town, but it's going to be home to a very large, traffic-disturbing, people-disturbing operation.
and I don't want to see every medium-sized town in this state starting up a casino operation, which is a slots barn, because most of the smaller ones will be slots barns, just because This passes without a moratorium, and this passes, and the commission has to take that as the state of the way everything's going to be from now on in New Hampshire.
Thank you.
Okay.
Just to review, and again, not going back into the long-winded testimony that we all heard and i guess i'm kind of confused at this point senator because you sponsored 51 sp 51 but yeah you're telling me maybe you can explain to me you just said that the charities and the operators are going to be negatively impacted by a moratorium how is that nope that's, that's not what I said.
That's exactly what you said.
What I said was if we don't pass this, the Senate version of the bill, the charities and the operators will be impacted because the players won't want to come in because the rake is so high.
Understood.
I still maintain and agree with the senator, and I think we all agree here, that this study commission needs to be done for many aspects of charitable, many aspects of charitable gaming.
The fact that we can sit here and acknowledge that this is a component that needs to be studied, I don't think we need to kick it down the road.
I don't think we need to weigh in whether the corner office is going to veto something.
That's not how I go by when I submit a piece of legislation, nor advocate for that piece of legislation or anybody else's piece of legislation.
There is a system in place when a veto takes place, and in September, we'll see how that goes.
But I stand firm on the fact that this has to be a component of this piece of legislation.
I'm feeling a little bit of an impasse here.
It sounds to me like we may not have agreement.
And I should mention for the record, I am involved in this industry a little bit of an impasse here.
And I should mention for the record, I am involved in this industry a little bit, but I'm hearing both sides here.
Are you hearing something different?
Do we have any chance to come together on anything or are we really at a place where we can't agree?
Thoughts?
So from my perspective, again, if the House is positioned, nothing passes unless we have a moratorium, we won't have anything pass.
Thank you.
so from my perspective again if the house's positions we nothing passes unless we have a moratorium we won't have anything pass um well just to the to the extent that we were talking about slot barns and and over and hhr houses just remember again by our by um rules and i believe statute there's a percentage relationship that has to occur between table games and HHR.
You can't have a pure HHR slot bond, right?
There has to be the ratio of money that is collected and used, which is by the number of machines, is controlled by the amount of table games that occurs.
And there's a ratio there.
So you can't have HHR without table games.
So just to make sure everyone's clear on the law and the regulation on that.
So.
There's no such thing as slots in New Hampshire, as you know.
So I don't want to get only corrective here, but yeah.
They just call them that a lot.
Representative, go ahead.
Yes, my newspaper said that this new place that they're building in levin and it's going to have 114 machines and i think it's something around 40 tables is that the ratio we're talking about so we're talking about revenue not numbers so you may have so it's the amount of revenue generated by table games directly relates to the amount of revenue generated by HHR.
And there's a ratio, I'm not exactly sure.
The commissioners, the executive directors here, you can probably answer exactly what that ratio is, but there is a ratio between the two.
You can't have one without the other.
I just wanted to add something tertiary that probably nobody's come up with, but I'm sure Senator D'Alessandro has seen this happen in the past.
Mark my words that right now we used to see poker machines in the back rooms of every restaurant.
All right.
We're going to see these things in the back rooms of every restaurant unless we screw down what's going on with this as a legislature.
And we have the means to do so yeah i just um i mean let's let's remember that what governor sunu vetoed was the five year moratorium and um he voted oh he vetoed the two year oh and the specific with the political.
And so I want to see something pass, and I want to risk it.
Right?
I want to make sure that we're not going to be our players and our citizens to take care of this.
Some of them early takes care of that as it relates to the political.
Well, I mean, to echo something Representative Doucette said is that we don't have to, you know, make our position based on that, right?
There are in September, once the veto comes down, there are actions that can be taken at that time to make sure this still happens.
we can have you know these changes plus the two-year moratorium and actions taken in in september could make sure that that is in place i was just wondering we have enough people in the house to pass to remove the veto.
I don't believe we do in the Senate.
Are you saying you don't?
Yes, I'm saying we don't.
I know what the Senate count looks like, and I don't anticipate you'll have the votes to overturn a veto, 16 votes.
You won't get them.
And so knowing that, knowing what I know, this bill moving forward helps our charities and helps our operators helps our players helps the citizens of new hampshire and i'd like to see something move forward rather than nothing move forward well i i would certainly hope over the summer prior to veto session in september your phones will be ringing and your email boxes will be filled and you listen to your constituents and you listen to the people of the state.
I've heard that before.
I've heard it for the last 25 years if you listen to the public, but this legislature never listened to the public.
And when you have an 80% favorability rating for a casino and the legislature votes against it, that's a problem.
I think our best bet, and all of you know where I stand on the issue, our best bet is the commission to look at what's in place.
And all of us know the charities have become a powerhouse in terms of this legislation.
They come every time there's a bill before us, and the legislature is cognizant of the fact that the charities are a power.
The situation at this point in time is how are the charities chosen?
Do they get the real percentage that they're entitled to?
These are are the vital things these are the most important the most important issues and i think the commission has the power to do that the commission will be funded there's 150 000 appropriation for the commission so the commission will be able to bring ample evidence to make sure that the kinds of things that you guys are concerned about will take place.
And as I say, as you know, in 1999, Arthur Clem and I proposed a piece of legislation that would have significantly modified gambling in the state of New Hampshire.
We would have retained Rocky Camp Park, would have retained horse racing, and we would have created a scenario where everybody benefited.
The Speaker of the House refused to accept that piece of legislation, refused to accept it.
Never made a vote on it, but refused to accept it.
I'm giving you a historical background because I was here.
And 25 times since then, I've produced a piece of legislation that dealt with the kinds of things that you're talking about.
Limitations as it related to where things would be, how things would be managed, a governing process, and a sharing process for revenue that was beneficial to all of the people of the state of New Hampshire, all of the counties, all of the cities, and so forth and so on.
I think if we looked at the big picture, which is, I think, key, and the big picture is this is going to go on.
It's got to be done properly, and if there is a limitation on the number of machines, that should be put in place.
But I think the commission should be given that responsibility if we have faith in a process of trying to make that happen.
And as I say, I've been around this for a long period of time.
And I've seen the ups and the downs.
And I've seen the proliferation that everybody said wouldn't occur.
It's occurred.
And it's occurred in places where people say they don't want it.
But it's there.
So I think the commission is really so important.
I truly believe that.
And I think your position is yours.
I appreciate that.
I respect that.
But I don't think the moratorium is going to be part of the deal.
But I truly appreciate your sentiment and your diligent work with the part of your community.
And I believe your community is in upheaval as we speak over the location.
Your communities, both of them, are in upheaval over this particular issue.
And I hope that a commission will settle that because I have great respect for everybody in the community.
I mean, I spent some of the greatest days of my life at Rocky Camp Park, and it doesn't exist anymore.
This doesn't exist anymore.
Thank you.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Thank you all for your comments.
So what I'm hearing, but please correct me if I'm wrong, is that we are not able to agree.
Jennifer Foer, if you'd advise me, please.
does that mean do we do we say that in a report or we just basically end the committee of conference that we both sides cannot agree Go ahead, please.
GO AHEAD, PLEASE.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, IT HAS TO BE A UNANIMOUS DECISION AT THE COC.
SO IT'S EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE HAS TO AGREE.
YES.
YEAH.
SO IF WE WERE TO PREPARE A REPORT, THEN EVERY SINGLE PERSON WOULD HAVE TO SIGN OFF.
WE'RE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO THAT, IT SOUNDS off we're not even close to that it sounds like so um yes yeah that is correct um that is correct that's why i'm just you know i have the committee of conference procedures right in front of me so i can properly do this um okay so if we agree we're not in agreement i will let ols know that and there will be that would be it okay thank you all for coming appreciate that Thank you.
Thank you.